foreign
[Music]
I'm an aging researcher by training I'm
a bioinformatician
but lately I'm trying to understand how
to measure Aging in different mammalian
tissues
and I will talk to you today about
epigenetic clocks and more generally
DNA methylation studies of Aging in
mammals
my entire talk is based on cytosine
methylation
cytosine methylation plays a critical
role in the development of vertebrates
as zygote could never differentiate into
other cells without methylation so
methylation is critical in vertebrates
not in invertebrates but vertebrates
yeah
my data are typically being generated on
an array platform the so-called Infinium
array from Illumina and I will be using
two types of Platforms in this talk or
this one is the human epic chip which
measures over 860 000 cytosines in the
genome and the other platform is a
custom methylation array that measures
37 000 cytosines in highly conserved
stretches of DNA
um this custom array is well suited for
comparative studies in mammals as I will
describe
and these arrays
provide methylation levels which are
really numbers between 0 and 1.
and the mammalian methylation array is
described in a preprint by Adriana
arneson and Jason Ernst
um and I will briefly mention some ideas
behind the design of the mammalian array
the top row shows you an oligonucleotide
sequence where on the right hand side
you see that there's a C and G pair that
cytosine guanine pair in humans but if
we want to use the same oligonucleotide
for other species we need to build in
tolerance to mutations for example in
chimps you see the yellow letter C is
different from the original
nucleotide sequence and in general as we
look at many different mammalian species
there will be mutations
and now the mammalian array can tolerate
a few of these mutations
per nucleotide sequence
and therefore we can measure CG cytosine
methylation in many different species
here I show you how many cytosines apply
to different phylogenetic orders the top
row shows you
primates and typically the mammalian
array profiles
um
at least 33 000 cytosines in primate
species
in the rodents you see we have about 28
000 in bats even more
and however as we go to evolutionarily
very distant species these mono tremata
for example we would have fewer than 15
000 side of things
but interestingly
70 percent of the cpgs map to athologous
genes in humans and that's very exciting
because imagine you study cytosines in a
mouse or a bat then typically these
cytosines are located near the same gene
as in humans
and that highlights really the virtue of
the mammalian array it allows you to
look at genes and Pathways that are
conserved between many different
mammalian species
and to date we have generated over 10
000 tissues from
175 mammalian species here I highlight
in red and in blue different
phylogenetic orders for which we have
animals
and um really
um many citations whales deer
um practically all animal species that
are being used in agricultural settings
bats and so on
and I will now describe epigenetic
clocks for mammals epigenetic clocks are
meant to measure the chronological ages
of different tissues and body parts not
just in humans but of course also in
different mammalian species
I'll start out with bats we just
published a paper
whose title says it all so we show that
one can predict Asian bats but also
methylation provides
insights into the exceptional longevity
of pets because some bad species can
live for more than 40 years
so here I show you in the scatter plot
our epigenetic clock on the x-axis we
report chronologic age of these
different bats and you see we have
samples from bats that were about 23
years old it's a pretty old bad samples
conversely we also had very young bats
newborns in essence and we had Wing
punches from these bats tiny amounts
and
um on in the panel I show you the Latin
names of 26 26 different bath species
um it turns out there are over a
thousand different bat species but at
least
um these 26 bad species are
representative of course of many of them
and um
what you see is a very high correlation
between the estimated value of H on the
y-axis and chronologic h
and the dots are labeled by the bad
species so it's really remarkable that
you can have one clock one epigenetic
Edge estimator one mathematical formula
that allows you to measure the ages of
all of these different bath species and
we're quite confident that this clock
for bats also generalizes to bad species
that were not part of our training set
by the way all the Scatter Plots I show
you are based on Cross validation or
independent data so these are unbiased
assessments of accuracy
um we also have highly accurate
epigenetic clocks for dogs they these
clocks apply to all dog breeds ideally
we like blood samples from dogs
and um here we profiled 51 different
pure dog breeds in collaboration with
Elaine Ostrander and so our clock is
remarkably accurate as you can tell and
the different colors correspond to
different dog breeds
we also have very accurate clock for
clocks for an amazing animal which is
the naked mole rat why is it amazing
because this animal has stopped
negligible senescence it doesn't seem to
age although this animal is roughly the
size of a rat
um it can live for up to 37 years so a
remarkable longevity
however as you can see from these
different panels that describe pan
tissue clocks meaning a clock that
applies to all tissues from the naked
mole rat panel B shows you an epigenetic
clock for blood samples from the naked
more rad panel C for liver panel e for
skin
so
um interestingly we can still build very
accurate epigenetic measures of age in
the naked mole rat even though on a
phenotypic level
it seems to have negligible senescence
um moving to rats rats of course live
far shorter lives than the naked mole
rats let's say less than four years
and here I show you
um
hand tissue clock for rats so we we have
very accurate aging measures for rats if
you carefully look at the x-axis
we restricted the analysis to animals
that were less than two and a half years
old
and um
the middle shows you a clock for brain
sample the right hand side a clock for
blood samples so we have very accurate
clocks for rats
however you can do something that seems
to be outlandish you can actually build
a clock that applies both to humans and
wrath at the same time so it's one
formula that allows you to estimate the
ages based on highly conserved cytosines
in humans and rats and we actually have
two such clocks one um is called the
human red clock for absolute age of
chronological age it really estimates
just calendar age
but we also have another human red clock
for what we call relative age relative
age is defined as the ratio between H
and the maximum lifespan of the species
so by definition the relative H is a
number between zero and one zero is the
age at Birth one means maximum lifespan
and why do we do it because relative age
allows us to
align these species and provide a
biologically more meaningful comparison
between species when it comes to
different aging rates the right hand
side shows you how our human red clock
applies to rad samples so the
correlation is still 0.93 it's
remarkably accurate
the left panel shows you the mixture of
human samples colored in green and the
orange samples which are the rat samples
so you see that this clock really
measures Aging in these animals of very
different lifespans
and
one could of course become more
ambitious which is well can one build a
universal mammalian clock that measures
age in all mammalian species
so we assembled a large collection of
species in order to build such Universal
mammalian clocks
and here I show you some results from
our preprint on bio archive
[Music]
we've built actually several Universal
clocks panel A and B describe Universal
clocks from placental mammals
panel C on the right shows you a
universal clock for marsupials I
distinguish eucerians or placental
mammals from you
marsupials because they're sequence
divergences
but long story short
um we have remarkably accurate universal
clock so each dot here is a tissue
sample from a different species the dots
are labeled by the species as outlined
in the previous
um Legend so here we have a different
species
and I think you can appreciate this very
high accuracy you know in in these
nearly 10 000 tissue samples
um but beyond epigenetic clocks you can
ask a simpler question can you find
cytosines that correlate with age
in many different mammalian species so
in other words one can do an epigenome
white Association studies of age across
this I think it was 128 species at the
time
and um and so this analysis is very
insightful because we do find cytosines
near genes that have very high
correlations with age in all species or
most species so there's one side of the
near the Gene
lhfpl4 and this cytosine has a very
strong correlation with age and pigs as
you see in panel B High correlation with
the a deer mouth panel C and primate
panel D which is a a particular monkey
the vervet monkey
um I want to come to another question
which um some people have called the
central question of biology
which is why do similar species such as
mammals have markedly different maximum
lifespans right why do humans live up to
122 years why do mice live for less than
five years why do some bats live for
over 40 years
and there's really a substantial
literature on that topic I mean it all
goes back to an essay from Aristotle
and people have uh found wonderful
answers in ecological studies in brief
animals that evade predators
often live substantially longer than
animals that have lots of predators
however the molecular reasons
um really require more detailed analyzes
and my anger to that question is of
course to look at methylation profiles
and epigenetics
and um
here I show you one cytosine which is
highly correlated with the maximum
lifespan across species so the y-axis
shows you the logarithm of the maximum
lifespan the x-axis is just one side a
single cytosine and you notice a very
strong negative correlation each dot is
a different species
that's one side of the question is what
if you combine many cytocines can you
build a more accurate
estimate of Maximum lifespan and the
answer is yes
so caesarly in my lab has developed a
multivariate predictor of Maximum
lifespan
based on a penalized regression model so
here each dot is a different mammalian
species and the correlation is 0.88 so
these estimators work remarkably well
um I want to now come to my favorite
mammal which is of course humans I'm
motivated by identifying and validating
anti-aging interventions in humans
and um
I want to describe the so-called human
pan tissue epigenetic clock
which was published in 2013
um and this which applies to all human
tissues and cell types that contain DNA
now
um
in general epigenetic clocks allow you
to create a curve here indicated in blue
or line that indicates the expected age
but people whose methylation age
estimate lie above this line they are
said to exhibit positive epigenetic age
acceleration and individuals who lie
below the lines
exhibit negative age acceleration
and
epidemiological Studies have shown that
people with positive epigenetic age
acceleration
are at a slightly higher risk of
various age-related conditions
and but it really depends on the clock
for example the pan tissue clock is not
the best mortality risk predictor rather
we use grimage that I will describe
later
but I want to
um now show you a more detailed analysis
of the pan tissue clock the pan tissue
clock allows you to measure Edge
acceleration in many different tissues
for example at a human adipose human
kidney human liver muscle and so on
and you can ask the question well which
age-related conditions are associated
with age acceleration in these different
human organs and tissues
and the Striking thing for me was that
hypertension really pops up so the first
row shows you that hypertension is
associated with epigenetic age
acceleration in adipose tissue kidney
liver muscle
um other conditions
um diabetes is associated with age
acceleration in the liver cardiac
disease is associated with atrial
acceleration in lung and adipose tissue
and so on
so
um these kinds of studies show us that
many age-related conditions are actually
specific to a given cell type or organ I
mentioned it because everybody studies
epigenetics and blood tissue because
blood is so readily available but blood
is not always informative you know so
you you want to carefully think about
what cell type should be profiled
um we also evaluated the effect of sex
on epigenetic age acceleration and
interestingly or perhaps you expected it
like everyone else a males show
epigenetic age acceleration
compared to females in really most
tissues that we looked at you know
certainly in blood
um
and um
also brain
and spleen and so on
the effects are relatively weakened
blood so males are maybe
one or two years older than females and
blood in other organs the effect may be
more pronounced
I now want to come to what we call the
second generation epigenetic clocks for
humans and these clocks should not be
interpreted as age as the Matrix but
rather as mortality risk estimators
there are two clocks that are widely
used in the literature the so-called
sino-age clock and the Grim age clock
um the Grim Edge clock is the best
mortality risk predictor
um it it
[Music]
um
really predicts lifespan
um when you use retrospective studies so
blood samples collected let's say in the
1990s then you have follow-up
information on these people and
um I'm sure if you have a reasonably
sized data set maybe 300 people you can
validate these claims you know that
grimage predicts lifespan
and um
how strong are the effects well if
you're in the top five percent of the
fastest ages According To Grim age than
your mortality risk is two times that of
the average person so and I will flesh
that out mortality risk means Hazard
ratio of death from from a Cox model
um so the Grim H clock was published by
akelu
and here I show you the results from a
large scale evaluation of that biomarker
um so we evaluated age acceleration
meaning we of course adjust for
chronologic age and sex in the analysis
we find that epigenetic age acceleration
based on Grim age is very strongly
associated with time to death and the
p-value is 10 to the minus 75.
um now let's carefully look at the
hazard ratio from this Cox model it's
1.1 which doesn't seem like a lot but
1.1 is the hazard ratio associated with
one year of each acceleration
and however in the bottom I show you the
calculation that eight years of
epigenetic age acceleration for a person
would be associated with a hazard ratio
2.2.14 so
um which is a strong effect about five
percent of the population have an
epigenetic age acceleration of eight
years or more conversely if you're lucky
enough that your epigenetic age
acceleration is let's say eight years
younger than expected then your hazard
ratio of death would be half that of the
average person
um here I show you a study of healthy
lifestyle in the women's health
initiative
and for these women we had
um blood measures of vegetable intake
more precisely blood measures of
carotenoid levels
and what we see is that yes women
post-menopausal women who eat vegetables
they age more slowly According To Grim
age the green column shows you the
p-value so there's no question that
these are very significant associations
at the same time these associations are
based on at least 2 200 women so these
are large sample sizes
at the bottom panel you see that
educational level is weekly but
statistically significantly associated
with slower epigenetic aging according
to the grimage clock exercise
um also and of course smoking is very
strongly associated with positive
epigenetic age acceleration According To
Grim agent that's a little bit by Design
because the Grim age clock involves
cytosines that change a lot with smoking
in general anything related to metabolic
syndrome obesity
insulin levels and so on are associated
with faster grimage
so to summarize that all you want to
lead a healthy lifestyle in order to
slow your epigenetic aging clock
The Next Step
s are really to
work on qualifying epigenetic biomarkers
as surrogate endpoints for human
anti-aging studies
we're not there yet because
in order to qualify any biomarker as a
surrogate endpoint you really need to
provide a very detailed
evidence that this is the case
what I can tell you is that Grim age
has been validated as a mortality risk
estimated by a dozen of a dozen papers
many by independent groups
um we're currently carrying out
longitudinal studies of grim age I want
to also mention
um we have
published a large-scale gvos of
um a grimage but also other epigenetic
clocks and we have polygenic risk scores
for these epigenetic biomarkers so you
can download them for free so if you
have snip markers you can
relate with polygenic risks scores to
your favorite age-related condition
we also carry out analytical validation
studies because we want to show that our
biomarkers have low test retest
variability
and a grimage stands out again by low
so brimage is our best
predictor of time to death time to heart
disease time to cancer it also relates
to early age menopause
um
grimage uses a methylation based
estimator of smoking pack years which
interestingly outperforms
self-reported smoking packages in
predicting lifespan
so in conclusion we have managed to
build epigenetic clocks for each
mammalian species that we analyzed we
have Universal clocks that apply to all
species and human clocks differ in
predictive accuracy for mortality risk
my pant tissue clock is a weak predictor
of mortality risk brim age is a strong
predict of mortality risk
um
DNA methylation strongly relates to
differences in maximum lifespan across
different species
and in humans methylation data are
predictive of mortality risk even after
adjusting for standard risk factors
methylation H will not replace any
standard clinical measure that are being
used
um as part of your physical it will not
replace blood pressure or lipid levels
or glucose measures so it complements
them but will not replace them and as
you design your own study you want to
think carefully
um about the tissue or cell type that
you want to study as I've shown you some
conditions
um are associated with age acceleration
in adipose tissue but not in blood or in
muscle tissue and so on so you can
generate methylation data from blood
saliva Buckle swaps even urine contains
enough DNA and so you can think about it
and want to end by thanking my many
collaborators I mentioned several people
already
and I'll stop here thank you so much